[Musique]
l'affaire Palma de la France bloquée de
7 mars chaque GPT mais aussi
l'environnement de cette émission de ce
nouveau numéro de Paf avec Véronique
Jérôme bonjour Patrice
de conférence à l'Université de Paris
Saclay
vous êtes toujours éditeur toujours
avocatrice ça va bien et toujours aussi
secrétaire de Conférence du stage ça
c'est ta vie donc ça malheureusement oui
ça restera ancien pour toujours et je
suis ravi d'accueillir Quentin Demers ça
fait un petit moment que vous étiez pas
venu vous êtes vous êtes toujours
conseillé municipal de Guyancourt
toujours et vous êtes maintenant ce que
vous n'étiez pas la dernière fois chargé
de mission ministère de la transition
écologique c'est ça justement
racontez-nous un peu
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que c'est un chargé de mission
au ministère de la transition écologique
alors sur mes missions particulières je
suis sur la transition des territoires
tradition transition territoriale on est
dans le contexte de la décentralisation
en France beaucoup de compétences qui
ont été transmises au collectivité
territoriales mais l'état encore son
rôle à jouer aussi dans l'accompagnement
de ces territoires à travers de
l'ingénierie à travers des financements
qui sont encore à la disposition
notamment des préfets et donc dans ce
cadre là on travaille à accompagné
donner un cadre aux collectivité
territoriales pour les accompagner sur
leur transition notamment je pense au
territoire ruraux qui manque beaucoup
d'ingénierie beaucoup de capacité à agir
directement et donc le but c'est de
faire qu'action de l'État soit cohérente
et faire aussi une cohérence avec la
volonté des élus au niveau local et
qu'on puisse construire des projets de
territoire à l'échelon des
intercommunalités par exemple pour
pouvoir ensuite lancer la transition et
pouvoir l'amplifier c'est très important
que le territoire participe cette
transition et c'est une vraie volonté de
l'État aujourd'hui c'est vraiment de
territorialiser cette planification
écologique cette transition écologique
chaque territoire est différent chaque
territoire des difficultés différentes
entre le sud le nord entre les côtes ou
les montagnes et donc c'est important
que l'action publique
n'agissent pas de manière
unitaire pour tout le pays mais bien
qu'elle s'adapte aussi à chaque réalité
et à chaque problématique de chaque
territoire c'est un des problèmes
d'ailleurs enfin pour en parler
longuement mais c'est peut-être un des
problèmes qu'on rencontre la France
aujourd'hui c'est encore le la
centralisation qui est encore très forte
on voit bien dans les dans les dans
l'édition même si on parlera des
retraites tout à l'heure mais c'est vrai
que voilà c'est c'est souvent les
décisions sont prises au sommet de
l'État elles arrivent comme ça
on en est discuté avant c'est vrai c'est
justement tout le but de mon travail et
des équipes du ministère en manière
générale sur cette question là en tout
cas c'est vraiment d'avoir une politique
territoriée où les élus ont vraiment
leur place c'est à travers différents
contrats qu'on peut soutenir entre
l'État les territoires on pousse de plus
en plus c'est l'état pousse de plus en
plus quand même les territoires et les
élus mais aussi les autres acteurs
économiques associatifs à prendre romain
aussi leur territoire et avoir vraiment
un rôle à jouer dedans et c'est un peu
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec on
pourrait parler du fond vert par exemple
où les préfets ont beaucoup la main
dessus donc on est vraiment sur une
logique où même si c'est décidé par
l'État même si l'état donne son cadre et
c'est le rôle de l'État de donner un
cage qui est national il n'empêche que
la décision est déclinée à la suite
jusqu'au plus fin du territoire jusqu'à
l'échelon communale et donc la les
maires depuis les grandes réformes de
centralisation de 82 etc on a quand même
une prise de pouvoir de plus en plus
forte des mers des présidents
d'intercommunalité des prisons
départements des présidents de région
qui ont gagné énormément de pouvoir et
de capacité à agir
sanitaire notamment et ils ont remplacé
parfois les tags étaient un peu
défaillants et on est sur une logique où
l'État les territoires doivent
travailler ensemble et laisser d'avoir
vraiment un trail une vraie coopération
qui se crée pas d'opposition entre le
National et le local et bien qu'on
puisse agir de manière cohérente à tous
les échelons je précise dès que vous
êtes chargé de mission au ministère de
la transition écologique vous n'êtes pas
au cabinet de du ministre vous êtes au
ministre d'ailleurs vous avez pas le
vous êtes toujours particulier c'est
toujours
je crois que le ministre de la
transition était ministre horizon il y a
peu de choses que d'autres cabinet
prennent quelqu'un de particulier
alors on va on va parler il y a beaucoup
de sujets en effet alors il y a un sujet
qui qui affole absolument les médias
depuis une dizaine de jours c'est
l'affaire Palmade alors tout le monde
lui tombe dessus
mais enfin est-ce que comme on a un
avocat ici ça me semble intéressant de
savoir si Palma des défendable ou pas
[Musique]
d'abord je ferais mieux on pourrait
faire quelques petits points juridiques
il est il est a priori poursuivre pour
homicide alors il est pour l'instant mis
en examen ça veut dire que le juge
d'instruction qui a été saisi par le
procureur de la République de Melun
estime qu'il existe à son encontre des
indices graves ou concordants qu'il ait
pu commettre un homicide involontaire à
l'encontre d'une personne pour l'instant
ils ont retenu le missile involontaire
bien que on ne soit pas à ma
connaissance absolument certain que le
foetus que portait cette malheureuse
passagère et bien respirer donc
il faut que le bébé est respiré avant de
mourir si la respirer donc il est né
viable à ce moment là le missine
involontaire peut être retenu c'est un
être une question qui est venu le
préciser c'est un être humain
si jamais le bébé n'a pas respiré ce
sont les expertises que les déciderons à
ce moment-là sans doute la qualification
concernant ce cet enfant changera et
prendra une autre orientation d'accord
deuxième point JURIDIQUE IMPORTANT c'est
la prise de stupéfiant
en principe c'est une circonstance
aggravante alors
dans tous les cas la prise de
stupéfiants est une circonstance
aggravante lorsque vous commettez une
infraction et que vous avez pris des
stupéfiants c'est une circonstance
aggravante ce n'est aucunement une
circonstance d'exemption ou
d'atténuation de la peine au contraire
c'est véritablement et dans tous les cas
une circonstance aggravante qui est
déterminée enfin qui est prise en compte
au moment de la détermination de la
peine de la personne qui commet une
infraction sous stupéfiante je vous pose
cette question parce qu'il y avait eu
cette affaire sa limite pour vos femmes
qui avait été
défenestrée c'était en 2017 et l'auteur
des faits était
sous l'emprise de la drogue et la Cour
de cassation a jugé qu'on pouvait le
piquer l'article qui permet de ne pas
être jugé justement pas alors en réalité
c'est très différent parce que c'était
pas à cette époque la personne qui avait
donc fait défenestrer
était en réalité victime de ce qu'on
appelle en psychiatrie une bouffée
délirante et effectivement cette bouffée
délirante avait été générée par la prise
de stupéfiants mais en réalité on était
quand même sur un état psychiatrique on
était sur un état psychique préexistant
et c'est pour ça que les experts qui
avaient vu la personne qui en examen
monsieur Traoré à l'époque avait
déterminé que son discernement était
abolies mais il était aboli en raison de
la maladie psychiatrique qui avait été
certes favorisée par la consommation de
stupéfiants mais c'est pas la
consommation de stupéfiants même qui
entraîne l'abolition du discernement et
donc l'exemption pénale c'est la maladie
psychiatrique donc il y a une vraie
différence entre ce qui s'est passé avec
Monsieur Traoré et la situation dans
laquelle et Monsieur Palmade dans un cas
on a une abolition du discernement qui
procède d'une maladie psychiatrique et
dans le second cas celui de Pierre
Palmade on a au contraire une
aggravation de la situation pénale dans
laquelle il est du fait de la
consommation de stupéfiants qu'il a
qu'il a fait avant de prendre le vol il
y a un mot qu'on va pas vous le
connaissiez vous c'est comme sexe
qui se joue autour de autour de
l'affaire palmate depuis quelques
semaines dans les médiums ça parle que
de ça
de toute façon qu'on ne parle que de ça
et la question qu'on se pose c'est à
quelle fin parce que finalement chacun
sa s'entretient le voyeurisme enfin moi
j'aime pas regarder par le trou de la
serrure et on a l'impression qu'on est
obligé d'écouter d'entendre et les pour
les contre et finalement on s'aperçoit
aussi que l'État ne t'intervient pas il
pourrait on pourrait attendre de l'État
qui intervienne au plaisir finalement
c'est très simple mais je dis ça mais je
le pense pas mais on pourrait se dire
finalement c'est l'état de mettre des
normes de réglementer et puis ben on
franchit les normes on est on est
pénalisé on est puni sinon on a toujours
cette quête c'est Paul Valéry qui disait
qu'en détail fort il nous oppressent
quand il est faible nous périssons donc
la question de comment arriver à être
pour l'État suffisamment crédible pour
désinciter à des comportements qui
seraient néfastes alors à soi-même à la
limite j'ai envie de dire peu importe
peu importe Pierre Palmade fait ce qu'il
veut de sa santé mais à partir du moment
celle des autres et c'est là le problème
c'est qu'il ce concernement individuel
qui qui déborde sur le gouvernement et
étatique et collectif concernant
étatique c'est à l'État d'apporter une
réponse a priori enfin d'une façon très
normative c'est ce qu'on pourrait dire
concernement collectif ça signifie que
moi ce qui me pose problème ici sur les
histoires de alors je ne suis pas
juriste donc quand j'entends homicide à
volontaire je n'arrive pas à comprendre
à volontaire ce que je me dis il y avait
une il y a un acte il y a peut-être pas
la volonté délibérée de tuer mais il y a
un acte qui fait que il y a une
intention qui fait que dans l'action de
procédure
mais quand on prend sa voiture et que
l'on sait qu'on a consommé des choses
illicites on sait qu'on peut
potentiellement on a quand même plus de
chances d'avoir un accident que si on
est sobre encore que si on est sobre et
qu'on n'est pas réveillé on peut je veux
bien comprendre mais on a
potentiellement plus de risques donc on
peut accepter de prendre ce risque on
peut dire après tout je peux prendre ce
risque mais c'est le risque qu'on fait
prendre aux autres je me souviens
d'avoir frôlé les choses de cette façon
quelqu'un qui arrive en face tu es sur
une autoroute aux États-Unis autoroutes
et une personne je vois un point noir
qui ne s'éloignait pas qui se rapproche
une personne qui arrive dans la même
fille en face et je me dis bon voilà
j'ai rien demandé elle est dans la
mauvaise file et moi je suis là je
qu'est-ce que je fais et bon j'ai eu de
la chance mais le lendemain dans les
genoux quand certaines personnes sous
influence et qui a fait quelques alors
il y a pas une mort mais il y a eu des
blessés
est prêt à apprendre à rétablir la peine
de mort pour Pierre Palmade et alors ok
c'est de la cocaïne a pris de la cocaïne
c'est pas bien il y a beaucoup plus
d'accidents dus à l'usage du cannabis
qui a l'usage de la de la cocaïne et sur
le cannabis tout le monde trouve ça très
bien je regardais il y a encore deux
jours un film produit par le service
public ou le policier la policier en
l'occurrence était ravi de tirer sur son
pétard quoi et on trouve ça très bien
alors on passe notre temps à nous dire
que faudrait un jour libéraliser le
cannabis que c'est bien de se défoncer
que c'est agréable que c'est moderne etc
et puis quand tout d'un coup ça va mal
alors là on dit ouh là là c'est pas bien
faudrait juste être cohérent soit on a
le droit de fumer on a le droit de se
défoncer on a le droit de se droguer et
à ce moment-là ben ok on prend des
risques on prend plus sa voiture ou on
pris le Seigneur si on y croit mais je
vois pas je ne comprends pas la
différence que qui est faite entre le
fait de tirer sur un pétard on sait très
bien que la moitié la moitié des
accidents qui sont se font ce cannabis
c'est la deuxième cause après l'alcool
donc c'est complètement terrible parce
que peu près ce que j'ai entendu d'un
médecin il semblerait que les traces
restent plus longtemps dans le sang
quand on fait une prise de sang des
traces de cannabis que d'autres
substances donc forcément il y a plus
accidents puisque ça reste plus
longtemps donc il y a une il y a
certainement un biais statistique ce qui
ne veut pas dire que ça n'excuse rien
sur le pétard et on voit dans quel état
ils sont et je suis désolé j'ai pas
envie de les croiser sur la route quoi
donc j'ai du mal à les croiser
normalement mais avec un véhicule
Jean-Charles alors on peut une petite
nuance en réalité le la loi ne fait pas
de distinction selon la matière
consommée donc que ce soit du cannabis
ou de la cocaïne la punition et la même
et très récemment il me semble que
c'était hier le ministre de la Défense
je parlais de l'opinion publique et le
ministre de l'Intérieur hier
la génération des 12 points exactement
dans l'hypothèse ou un conducteur serait
pris après avoir consommé des
stupéfiants donc on voit bien que à
nouveau il y a pas de distinction qui
est faite alors on peut discuter de du
bien fondé de la nécessité de la mesure
ce serait encore un long débat je pense
qu'à mon avis on débordera un petit peu
il y a un débat pour savoir si à chaque
fois qu'il y a un fait divers il faut
une nouvelle loi il faut etc et est-ce
utile ou pas j'ai mon avis sur le sujet
mais vu que vous ne m'avez pas posé la
question
j'aimerais bien vous le donner en tout
cas concernant la distinction entre et
cannabis a priori l'opinion publique
tendrait à s'uniformiser sur le fait que
il ne faut pas en prendre avant de
commencer
je veux bien que dans le pays où il y a
pas la même après on considère pas de la
même façon le le cannabis et le les
autres drogues mais
ce qui en matière de conduite je crois
pas que de qu'on fasse beaucoup de
différence là-dessus je me suis sans
doute mal exprimé ou alors vous m'avez
mal compris mais le président mal
compris
je trouve bizarre dans l'opinion
publique qui est là remontée contre
Palma que en l'occurrence cette opinion
n'arrête pas de dire mais c'est
merveilleux de fumer c'est merveilleux
je vous dis dans les fruits
etc et douleurs des choses comme ça je
veux dire la majorité des gens sont
censés prennent pas du cannabis contre
les douleurs
favoriser le le la consommation
dans les hôpitaux des partis politiques
qui qui prônent la libération du
cannabis à contrôler
on pourra dire tiens encore
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a des arguments
assez forts pour les libéralisation
d'ailleurs
sur je pense pas que l'État il a il a
pas qu'un volet répressif il y a la
répression qu'on était il y a un
problème oui mais il y a aussi la
question de la prévention et je pense
que quand on parle de demande de
consommation de drogue il est important
que
et notamment quand on parle notamment
des jeunes on sait que c'est souvent au
lycée que ça peut commencer les
consommations de drogue qu'on est aussi
dès le lycée comme on peut la voir déjà
sur la sexualité par exemple avoir ce
travail là d'accompagnement des jeunes
pour bien leur expliquer les risques et
aussi les les voies de sortie parce que
faut bien sûr
ça se fait mais quand même de manière
très légère la même façon pour la
sexualité ou quand on parle d'égalité
fameux ce sont des choses qu'il faut
passer dès l'école il faut faire de la
prévention auprès des jeunes et pas la
prévention un peu morale à dire c'est
pas bien consommer c'est à dire que il
est possible parce que comme ça sur leur
chemin euh d'apprentissage de la
maturité il est possible qu'il rencontre
de la drogue sur leur chemin la question
asse
peut-être aussi avoir quand même un
contrôle de ce qui se passe à la sortie
des collèges et des écoles parce que là
c'est oui mais le problème critique
comment comment l'étage ou la politique
du chiffre a plus plutôt préférée
attraper les petits dealers plutôt
qu'être attraper les les gros mafieux
qui dirigent tout ça la question pour
moi c'est vraiment la prévention de
comment on accompagne les jeunes
là-dedans et comment on leur montre bien
ce que on parle aussi parler de la
question d'addiction dans tous ces
questions là c'est comment une fois
qu'on est tombé dedans on offre les
sorties pas en stigmatisant la personne
à dire tu es drogué tu es mal tu es en
prison mais bien de proposer un vrai
suivi psychologique médicale gratuit qui
lui permettra de sortir puisque ce
droguer c'est pas que se faire du mal
c'est aussi faire mal à la société comme
on peut le voir avec les accidents que
ça peut causer et donc il y a un vrai
besoin d'un service public derrière ça
pour accompagner et comme ça existe déjà
aujourd'hui mais il faut le développer
il faut vraiment mettre les moyens
derrière pour pouvoir suivre ces
populations là il faut vraiment que
voilà savoir que dès qu'on tombe dedans
comme pour l'alcoolisme on peut s'en
sortir et que la société met en place ce
qu'il faut pour qu'on puisse s'en sortir
pour le bien de tout le monde et vous
avez prononcé un mot potentiel sauf
parce que c'est si on résume l'affaire
Palmade au fond c'est un drame de
l'addiction en fait c'est c'est ça la
difficulté de s'en sortir je ferai
meilleur je m'adressais
non mais c'est vrai qu'on attaque même
les plus proches amis de de Palmade le
lâche euh
je sais pas c'est très courageux ou pas
vrai
si vous étiez son avocat parce que la
question oui que je me posais c'est
est-ce qu'il est défendable il y a pas
le mode comment vous le défendriez si
jamais vous répondre pour répondre à
votre question en réalité ils font
revenir à la notion même de défendre
qu'est-ce que c'est défendre en réalité
défendre c'est pas excusé c'est pas
justifié c'est pas nécessairement
expliqué non plus c'est dans la
situation de PERP Palmade simplement
faire en sorte que
cette espèce de tourbillon médiatique
dans lequel il est n'emporte pas tout
nécessairement par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé on a alors une femme qui a
perdu son enfant on a une personne qui
est toujours dans le coma on a un enfant
qui est toujours dans le coma ça génère
de fortes récriminations sociales et
c'est bien naturel en réalité je pense
que le rôle de l'Avocat
concernant la situation de Monsieur
Palmade c'est véritablement de faire en
sorte que la sanction qui sera la sienne
sur le plan pénal sur le plan civil soit
le plus juste la plus juste possible et
qu'on ne cède pas à cette tentation de
la vengeance qu'on ne sait pas à cette
tentation de la punition facile et que
infini la loi lui soit correctement
appliquée voilà
je pense ce qu'il faut
ce à quoi il faut s’échainer concernant
la situation de Monsieur palp Pierre
Palmade c'est véritablement permettre
qu'il est la sanction la plus juste
possible et que le juge ne soit pas
tenté de céder à une forme de facilité
et à une forme de réprobation que bien
évidemment génère l'attitude de Monsieur
Palma voilà c'est maintenant vous dire
ce que je mettrai en place moi comme
système de défense de Pierre Palmade je
n'ai pas accès au dossier mais je sais
pas ce qu'il contient les choses vont
encore évoluer donc je ne peux pas vous
répondre précisément mais à la question
Pierre Palmade est-il indépendable je
vous réponds évidemment non et je vais
même plus loin je pense que Pierre
Palmade doit être défendu parce que s'il
n'est pas défendu il y a pas de procès
équitable et s'il y a pas de procès
équitable à ce moment là il y a plus de
démocratie et donc Pierre Palmade doit
impérativement être défendu et il doit
être bien défendu pour que on puisse
sortir par le haut de cette terrible
affaire ou en tout cas que la justice et
que notre société puisse sortir par le
haut de ce terrible drame de ce terrible
accident de la route qui a déjà coûté
alors qui a peut-être goûter la vie à
une personne et qui en coûtera peut-être
la vie à d'autres voilà mais c'est vrai
que vous avez raison d'insister là
dessus parce qu'on entend beaucoup moi
j'ai entendu beaucoup des gens comme ça
oui il faut faire un exemple
c'est parce qu'il est connu qu'il faut
qu'il soit plus sévèrement il y a rien
de pierres que l'exemple en matière
judiciaire parce que l'exemple en
matière judiciaire ça sert uniquement à
faire en sorte que la sanction soit vue
et non pas qu'elle est une utilité
criminologique ou sociale donc
véritablement l'exemple en matière
judiciaire c'est le pire de ce qu'il
peut advenir ça n'a aucune aucune
utilité non il ne faut pas faire
d'exemples de Pierre Palmade il faut
justement faire en sorte qu'il soit jugé
comme n'importe quel citoyen et que à
faire médiatique ou pas il est le droit
à la même justice que que si c'était une
personne autour de cette table peut-être
pas Jean-Charles qui est commis les
mêmes faits
ce que vous disiez d'ailleurs on
discutez c'est un fait divers quoi
avec Maître non il y a aucun souci la
seule chose moi ce que j'aimerais c'est
que Pierre Palma normalement soit
condamné à avoir un chauffeur quand on a
son argent quand on a son addiction il y
a aucune raison de conduire c'est ça
c'est le seul truc je ne comprends pas
pourquoi ce type n'a pas de chauffeur
c'est juste un truc
qui lui avait proposé de combien c'est
vraiment le coup de pied de là normatif
il est passager il se défonce avec
Pierre Palmade et il va en rajouter une
couche pour enfoncer pierre palourde et
pourtant je lui ai dit de pas conduire
mais ça c'est c'est juste aberrant enfin
je veux dire
il y a maintenant des affaires de
pédophilie soit disant enfin là aussi
pas très clair enfin c'est pas comment
il y a un type qui dénonce mais qui n'y
est pour rien
mais c'est ça qui est assez ça qui est
absolument terrible à nouveau dans cette
affaire c'est que maintenant mais on
parlait du jeu parler de tourbillon
médiatique tout à l'heure on est
vraiment vraiment dans ces dans cette
situation là la l'information a été
balancée comme cela on est simplement au
stade de l'enquête mais maintenant la
difficulté c'est que à nouveau sur la
tête de perpial il est mentionné
consultation potentielle d'image de
période et la difficulté c'est que là on
est véritablement dans la phrase de
Beaumarchais quel omnier qui a le mien
il en restera toujours quelque chose
dans quelques mois peut-être que cette
enquête n'aura rien donné mais bon ça
n'intéressera plus personne on aura
simplement associé à Pierre Palmade la
consultation de d'image
pédopornographiques à nouveau et c'est
là où je pense que il faut prendre
quelques précautions et c'est là où la
défense de Pierre Palmas s'impose c'est
qu'il a le droit comme tout le monde à
ce que il est sur ce plan là une
présomption d'innocence c'est pas être
jeté en pâture notamment sur des
éléments c'est sur une enquête qui n'est
encore qu'à un stade de grands grands
début puisque pour l'instant on est que
sur une dénonciation on parle sur votre
secret de l'instruction il y a pas de
secret de l'enquête si il y a une un
secret de l'enquête comme le secret de
l'instruction le secret quoi alors en
principe donc on ne veut pas
alors si je rejoins un petit peu enfin
ça revient un petit peu sur ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure sur le rôle de
l'État et sur les choses qui devraient
être faites pour préserver certains
éléments si jamais on était absolutiste
sur la protection il devrait y avoir des
poursuites qui sont faites pour
violation du sucré l'enquête et
violation du secret de l'instruction
seuls peuvent communiquer en principe
dans le cadre d'enquête et
d'instructions les procureurs de la
République qui vont qui peuvent
délivrer à la presse les éléments
choisis du dossier seul eux peuvent le
faire les autres ne peuvent pas de ne
doivent pas livrer des éléments
d'enquêtes des éléments d'instruction
donc il lutter préférable il luttaient
souhaitable pour le bien commun un petit
peu aussi pour Pierre palmat que ces
éléments-là restent dans le strict giron
de la justice et ne soit pas livré aux
journalistes
le ministre récemment Darmanin qui
envisage de renforcer les de renforcer
des sanctions et de considérer comme
étant une sanction plus fortes
le problème c'est qu'il y a un politique
qui a dit tout de suite mais si la
sanction est plus forte et si on retire
le permis mais on aura on aura pas
l'efficacité on aura plus de gens qui
rouleront son permis donc je crois que
si on n'est même pas si en tant que
politique on ne croit même pas
d'efficacité parce que ce qu'il disait
c'est que finalement si on prive si j'ai
bien compris on retirerait
le permis sur le champ et considérer
mais on vous prend on prend le permis et
vous vous débrouillez pour rentrer chez
vous mais et le problème c'est qu'un peu
difficile disait mais ce genre de mesure
ne marchera pas parce que toute façon
quelqu'un qui aurait qui serait dans
cette situation ça n'empêchera pas de
continuer à rouler même sans permis donc
il y a plus de 800000 personnes qui
conduisent sur le chemin
le premier mais là c'est qu'on avait
même pas rendre crédible une mesure on
peut la rendre la plus la plus dure
possible elle est pas crédible
l'analyse est parfaitement exacte mais
d'autant plus que cette mesure
existe déjà dans la loi c'est-à-dire que
ce que veut faire Gérald Darmanin c'est
générer une automaticité sur le retrait
du permis de conduire l'invalidation
pour des faux de points dans l'hypothèse
ou une personne aurait conduit en étant
sous l'emprise de stupéfiants mais en
réalité la loi prévoit déjà cette
possibilité là lorsque vous êtes lorsque
vous êtes contrôlé après avoir conduit
sous l'emprise de stupéfiant vous êtes
donc passible d'une comparution devant
le tribal correctionnel et vous avez
aussi la possibilité de faire l'objet
d'une rétention de votre permis de
conduire par décision préfectorale donc
cette décision est ce dispositif existe
déjà le tribunal correctionnel lorsqu'il
est saisi par le procure de la
République après que une personne ait
été contrôlée en ayant conduit après
avoir consommé des stupéfiants peut tout
à fait prononcer une annulation du
permis de conduire on est à livrer ceci
d'ailleurs on est à livrer ceci donc
cette mesure existe déjà on voit très
bien ce que fait Gérald Darmanin par ce
biais parce qu'il dit voilà on supprime
12 points en revanche les petits
dépassements de vitesse on pourrait très
bien ne pas supprimer de points c'est du
sympa avec ceux qui travaillent c'est un
peu du Sarko c'est un peu du sarcoolisme
on voit que ça avait été très profitable
ça pour le coup on va peut-être dévier
un petit peu sur un sujet un peu plus
politique on je pense que Gérald
Darmanin est en train tranquillement de
ce présidentialiser et il reprend un
petit peu les vieilles recettes qui
avaient fonctionné et surf sur la vague
de l'émotion qui a été générée par
l'accident causé par Pierre Palmade mais
en tout cas cette mesure est à mon avis
de mesure premièrement
inutile sur le plan junioridique et
judiciaire parce que les dispositions
existent déjà et que deuxièmement
effectivement on peut s'interroger sur
le bien fondé en matière de société et
de santé de de cette de cette mesure là
donc effectivement est-ce que ça ne
générerait pas plus de personnes qui
conduirait son permis la question peut
être posée et il est fort probable que
si ça s'assoit terriblement
quant à vous de faites une année
politique dans de
politiquement je j'ai presque envie de
dire c'est quand même assez étonnant
qu'en pleine période des retraites on
parle autant de ses affaires là et je
trouve c'est quand même c'est quand même
c'est quand même dommage enfin c'est
quand même dommage dans le débat public
de manière générale dans les médias que
que des chaînes prennent autant de temps
sur ça alors qu'on a une un grand
chantier et une grosse réforme qui est
qui est présente actuellement dans le
débat parlementaire et qu'on pourrait
alimenter encore plus au départ chaque
jour pour alimenter les infos qu'on
continue on peut tout dire sauf qu'on
n'est pas beaucoup parlé des retraites
il y a pas de souci de juste une
dernière chose que si on termine avec ce
sujet vous disiez tout à l'heure que
tout le monde le tourne le dos à Palmade
il y a quand même un type François
Rollin que vous connaissez voilà qui qui
lui le défend il dit voilà au-delà de
tout ce qui est on peut lui reprocher et
c'est à dire mais ça reste mon ami ça
reste quelqu'un voilà alors que c'est
vrai que dans le showbiz ils sont tous
un peu tendance à évacuer le bébé Claude
humain genre si jamais on n'a pas assez
dit qu'il était pas sympa les locations
de nos propres spectacles vont
s'effondrer et là on voit bien tout le
monde freiner des cas de fer donc ce qui
n'est pas très très
bien sur scène d'ailleurs enfin dans les
ouais mais c'est la seule définition de
l'ami au sens véritable du terme c'est
cette c'est exactement voilà
quand on a besoin
d'amis allez on parle de retraite alors
les retraites peuvent tous pas se jouer
peut-être dans la rue le le 7 mars
[Musique]
mobilisation le 7 mars
d'autant plus importante et quand un
démarche tourne un peu vers vous que
en particulier à cause de vos amis de
LFI le débat n'a pas pu aller jusqu'au
jusqu'au bout notamment jusqu'à cet
article 7 qui prévoit l'allongement de
travail jusqu'à 64 ans le débat
parlementaire il est pas fini on finit
la première séquence à l'Assemblée
nationale
et puis après la commission mixte
paritaire
il n'empêche que
on a eu des stratégies différentes à
l'Assemblée mais il dit ça parce que le
Parti communiste c'était pas tout à fait
d'accord avec avec le gouvernement de
LFI enfin de la nupasse sur la stratégie
la stratégie sous différentes c'est sûr
il y a quand même une unité après sur le
sur la bataille des retraites et tous
les partis sont d'accord tous les partis
et tous les syndicats faut pas oublier
qu'on a aussi une intersedicale qui lien
avec même le pôle réformiste des
syndicats qui continuent à être contre
la réforme qui est pourtant un pôle qui
a l'habitude de
négocier les réformes avec le
gouvernement donc moi ce que je vois
c'est OK à l'Assemblée on a des
difficultés sur sur des accords entre
les parties mais il n'empêche que sur la
ligne à avoir et sur la position par
rapport à la réforme on est toujours sur
le même unité que ce soit pour les
partis politiques de gauche comme pour
le poste syndical est-ce que vous pensez
que une forte mobilisation elle sera
probablement forte le 7 mars
a les moyens de faire reculer le
gouvernement si au contraire du côté
législatif des choses se passent plutôt
bien pour lui parce que on a on a on a
des raisons de penser que le Sénat va
plutôt être favorable à la réforme et
que la commission
paritaire entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
va va aller dans le sens de la de la
réforme voulue par le gouvernement
on a la rue d'un côté le législatif de
l'autre quoi on est face à le problème
c'est que
l'exécutif aujourd'hui n'a pas de
majorité en tant que tel il doit
s'allier avec différents autres parties
pour avoir une majorité
il n'est pas vrai que le président a été
réélu sur son programme il a été élu
contre contre le RN et on a été on a été
très nombreux on a été très nombreux
quand on a que 20% au premier tour et
que ont réussi à gagner après grâce à la
voie de la console
la question c'est qu'on est sur une
réforme
10% des Français qui sont contre la
réalité pourcentage de nouveauté
c'est moi je pense que c'est le problème
de la 5e République c'est-à-dire que
quand vous vous mettez à vouloir faire
votre propre réforme vous êtes réduit à
votre score du premier tour et c'est à
dire que là ça fait 27 pour en gros 27
pour Macron et 5% pour Pécresse en gros
ça fait 32% et vous avez 68% des gens
qui sont contre la réforme
c'est à dire que quand on est populaire
quand on est au pouvoir
on peut faire des réformes là on peut
rien faire quand on est au pouvoir
normalement on est élu effectivement par
une majorité forte et au moins une
majorité en tout cas on a un état de
grâce et c'est là qu'il faut faire les
réformes en début de mandat parce qu'on
a le soutien politique et on désinvestit
dans cette crédibilité c'est une
réactions
n'a pas été lu démocratiquement moi je
laisse personne
qui ont voté pour lui au deuxième tour
n'étaient pas favorable
correctement on a voté pour pour ma puce
en permanence en France avec des
manifestations sans arrêt des grèves en
permanence etc vous trouvez ça serait
démocratique
les manifestations actuellement je les
ai toutes faites et oui
c'est eux c'est eux qui payent ce qu'on
perd des jours de travail je perds des
jours de travail en faisant grève dans
ce mouvement donc c'est aussi mon qui
touchait et encore moins je suis pas
loin bien payé mais il y a aussi
beaucoup de gens beaucoup d'ouvriers
d'employés qui font grève et qui perdent
des sommes monstrueuses pour eux et qui
sont obligés de manger des pâtes toute
tout le mois pour réussir à tenir qu'il
n'arrive pas à payer leur facture à
cause de ça donc on est sur des gens qui
sont sur un conflit qui est quand même
assez dur et qui restent pourtant très
très calme dans les rues qui manifeste
calmement dans les autres il n'y a pas
vu le département et moi je trouve que
le message il est extrêmement il est
extrêmement compliqué pour le
gouvernement c'est-à-dire que d'un côté
on a un mouvement les gilets jaunes qui
étaient violents on a lâché du lest là
on a un mouvement qui ramène encore plus
de monde qui est pacifique qui ne pose
pas de problème et on a zéro négociation
le gouvernement négocie qu'avec les
groupes de LR à l'Assemblée et au Sénat
il ne négocie pas avec les syndicats
avec la personne syndicale il n'entend
même pas la CFDT je comprends qu'il ne
veut pas parler CGT s'il a envie c'est
après c'est leur problème mais que même
la CFDT ne veuille pas que même la CD
soit présent dans les manifestations ça
pose quand même problème ça veut dire
que le moment où la CFDT dit on ne peut
pas parler de de de passage de l'âge à
64 ans c'est assez difficile de négocier
le cœur de la réforme ça veut dire qu'il
n'y a pas une réforme des retraite il y
a plusieurs possibilités de réforme des
retraites probablement si on va en
parler tout à l'heure
il y a quand même la question aussi de
même quand on a un trou un déficit et
quand même plein de façons de remplir de
manière différente et dans ce cas-là
quelle est la concertation qui a été
faite avec les syndicats pour négocier
cette chose là il y a plein de façons de
remplir un trou et la seule le seul
chose qui a été dite ça a été même la
CFDT et même pour rallonger le temps de
cotisation là on parle pas de ça on
parle de décaler l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite ce qui est complètement
injuste et c'est ça qui a bloqué et qui
a braqué les syndicats donc pour moi on
est sur un acte d'autorité d'un
président qui veut rappeler qu'il est le
président c'est lui qui décide et donc
il veut marquer le coup avec quelque
chose qui est un populaire pour montrer
que c'est lui qui décide et qu'il est
fort et qu'il a l'autorité mais derrière
il fracture le pays et en facture dans
le pays il ouvre derrière la porte de ce
que nous on a essayé de bloquer en 2014
je reconnais sa légitimité donc on a le
droit de faire voter les députés qui ont
été élus leurs vous allez me dire encore
que les députés de la majorité
présidentielle ont été élu avec 12% des
voix ou je ne sais quoi vous allez
remettre ça en cause mais
la majorité des gens voteront des
députés voteront et il faudra accepter
la démocratie la démocratie c'est ça
quand même
15000 amendements on aurait pu discuter
mais il faut bien peser les conséquences
même quand on a été élu il faut bien
peser les conséquences des actions que
l'on fait mais quand on a un programme
et je me suis trompé
on est contrats aussi à ça c'était comme
si on a un programme et on a aussi nos
habitants et quand on a nos habitants
ils sont en pleine crise énergétique en
crise en crise tout augmente dans tous
les sens donc c'est peut-être le pire
moment pour faire une réforme comme ça
sans négociation avec les syndicats sans
négociation avec les corps
intermédiaires c'est un peu plus
compliqué
si on prend l'exemple de la première
réforme
intelligemment les choses pour essayer
au moins de toute façon et avoir une
vraie vision pour le pays je pense que
les Français ils sont prêts à beaucoup
de sacrifices mais il faut leur vendre
en tout cas une vision du pays là on est
sur une réforme gestionnaire sur le faux
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
disent
l'espérance de vie augmente c'est une
réalité la démographie on fait moins
d'enfants c'est aussi une réalité les
déficits sont là et donc les solutions
c'est quoi c'est soit baisser les le
montant des retraites soit augmenter les
impôts soit allongé le temps de travail
je pense que vous êtes pour la baisse
des des retraites ou pour l'augmentation
des impôts alors déjà il y a les
différences entre l'impôt et les
cotisations sociales on parle de la
retraite donc c'est les caisses de la
Sécurité sociale c'est-à-dire on cotise
on a le droit c'est pas la même chose
que l'impôt qui est un fonctionnement
différent qu'elle a la main de oui il
faut le financer il faut financer il me
faut déjà rappeler une chose c'est que
la productivité des travailleurs
français a énormément augmenté depuis
les années 50 c'est à dire que même si
on vit plus longtemps on est tellement
plus productif et même beaucoup plus
productif que depuis les années 50 que
finalement on peut payer plus de choses
donc ce qui a été voulu et ce qui était
décidé par les Français et par leur vote
par leur vote dans le passé et par
notamment le Conseil National de la
Résistance c'était de créer un nouveau
temps de la vie c'est à dire qu'on est
les plus mourir au travail on allait
pouvoir vivre entrer dans une vraie
nouvelle étape après après le travail
qui est la retraite et qui est même pas
un temps sans travail ils sont trahi
encore quand on a la retraite mais on
travaille de manière libre c'est à dire
qu'on ne travaille pas en tant que
salarié lié à l'entreprise on peut
décider ce qu'on fait par exemple aider
à la famille aider dans les associations
être réduite financement
donc il y a les alliagements de
cotisation sociale qui ont été faits
dans tous les sens le le cice c'est
aussi encore autre chose mais c'est des
milliards et des milliards
il faut qu'elle paye juste ce qu'elle
doit payer c'est à dire que les
allègements
il faut les reprendre excusez-moi vous
voyez bien que là on est dans on n'a
jamais eu aussi peu de chômage
aujourd'hui et que si on a aussi peu de
chômage c'est probablement parce que le
fait qu'on est baissé les charges des
entreprises ça ça paye si je peux dire
aussi simple que ça soit juste
comme ça
un pays extrêmement riche l'argent il
est là
par rapport à donc riche ne veut rien
dire c'est dans les potentialités ce qui
est dommage c'est que d'un côté comme de
l'autre quand on considère que la
solution ça doit de faire payer Pierre
Paul ou Jacques c'est que c'est une
solution je dirais à très court terme et
qui n'ira pas très loin l'idée c'est de
savoir comment retrouver de la
croissance comment faire en sorte que la
croissance revienne et si la croissance
revient vous élargissez le gâteau c'est
pas la peine de prendre une pierre une
pierre une part de plus au voisin ces
gâteaux est plus large on vous regarde
même système de de prélèvement et on a
des recettes qui sont plus importantes
et si on a des recettes plus importantes
on réduit le déficit et si on réduit le
déficit à la main que sera content qui
nous disait encore ce matin sur je crois
que c'est son repas voilà que on a quand
même 3000 milliards de dettes à financer
et que si on ne fait pas cette réforme
les marchés financiers vont avoir peur
alors il a tort il a raison je peux me
prononcer
parce que la signature de la France
c'est les altérée par le fait que on ne
rassure pas quelque part les marchés
financiers
etc la dette de l'État c'est pas la tête
de la sécurité sociale la sécurité
sociale encore une fois c'est une autre
structure
on parle de milliards de milliards c'est
peut-être des milliards mais le budget
de la Sécu c'est plus grand que le
budget de l'État et donc en fait
finalement quand on regarde les
pourcentages on parle de quelques
pourcentages de déficit je dis pas que
c'est pas le problème
occidentaux la question c'est pourquoi
on a besoin à ce point-là de faire une
réforme maintenant alors que les choses
sont à peu près stabilisées qu'on est
sur des choses qui prennent beaucoup de
temps pourquoi pourquoi se presser à
faire une réforme tout de suite qui va
être violente
c'est une question politique
j'apporte pas une réponse comme ça le
fait est qu'il y a plein parce que c'est
un dernier mandat qu'il faut quand même
il faut avoir un acte d'autorité pour
dire je veux marquer l'histoire je veux
être que la partie des présidents qui
ont marqué en faisant réforme populaire
que j'ai réussi à tenir que je suis un
grand leader peut-être que tu as raison
c'est qu'il faut il faut il faut aussi
rassurer même si ça vous plaît il faut
des marchés financier il faut il faut un
vrai débat avec faut pas oublier que
c'est les Français qui travaillent c'est
eux qui produisent la richesse ils ont
le droit aussi de dire qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent faire cet argent cette richesse
là aujourd'hui vous passez je dirais à
la limite vous repasser le mistigri aux
générations futures donc là c'est un
choix la génération présente accepte
peut-être un effort au motif que ça
allaitera la charge pour les générations
futures ou alors on considère que on
pénalise les générations présentes qu'il
n'y a pas lieu de le faire parce qu'on
pourrait très bien trouver des moyens de
financement autre et faire en sorte que
le système fonctionne il y a peut-être
pas péril en la demeure ou alors le site
le système est en faillite comme disait
Gabriel Attal et là il est vrai qu'on a
tous ses discours et tout ce débat et on
va revenir sur des gens familial vous
voulez vous êtes un peu seul autour de
cette table donc ça me donne envie de
vous défendre aussi longtemps que vous
avez vu un procureur particulièrement
véhément contre vous
juste simplement une une observation
deux observations la première c'est
assez rigolo de voir ce que pense enfin
les Européens sur la réforme des
retraites et sur ce qui se passe
actuellement en France j'ai lu récemment
un article du Financial Time pas connu
pour être extrêmement à gauche qui
explique que la retraite en France c'est
une époque bénie que notre système est
absolument incroyable que tout
fonctionne parfaitement et c'est là où
ça a un petit côté savoureux et ça va
vous faire plaisir
ce journaliste du Financial Time qui je
vous disais pas connu pour être
spécialement à gauche propose pour
financer les retraites que les 5% des
Français les plus riches donc ceux qui
génèrent le plus de richesses
travaillent jusqu'à 68 ans pour financer
les retraites c'est absolument
incroyable c'est vraiment extrêmement
particulier de voir comment à l'étranger
on voit notre système de retraite et
comment on envisage la réforme qui est
actuellement en cours ça c'est la
première observation qui va vous faire
plutôt plaisir je suis navré je me
détache un petit peu sur la deuxième ce
que je regrette un petit peu c'est que
le débat parlementaire était à ce point
pauvre et à ce point
phagocyté même désespérant enfin c'est
une réforme qui
je suis assez d'accord avec vous sur
certains points qui nécessitent je pense
que on met un petit peu de coeur et un
petit peu et qui puisse générer un petit
peu des mois je le comprends
parfaitement je déplore vraiment que on
est atteint ce niveau de pauvreté dans
le débat parlementaire il y avait
véritablement possibilité pour faire
mieux et pour faire autre chose que cela
et ça je pense que c'est un petit peu à
mettre à vos débit notamment de la
nupesse
il faut peut-être distinguer entièrement
utile parce qu'on a quand même réveillé
des choses le gouvernement est venu avec
une réforme en disant qu'elle était
juste et finalement on remarque
différentes choses tellement les règles
que la pénibilité finalement elle est
pas être prise en compte donc c'est à
dire que moi je suis pas contre les
Français sont pas contre une réforme
manière générale la question c'est
quelle réforme et non défend la question
du référendum par exemple dans l'idée
que on est honoré un vrai débat
démocratique avec toutes les
possibilités ouvertes aux Français et
les Français choisissent ce qu'ils
veulent vraiment on parle de choses
c'est aussi favorable à ça mais c'est
vrai que tout le monde dit que personne
ne répond aux questions et nous ne
sommes pas égaux j'entends bien sur la
question des plus riches travailler plus
typiquement tous les métiers ne se
valent pas il faut vraiment prendre la
question de la pénibilité qui est une
différence d'espérance de vie afin
d'ouvrier et un quatre qui sont énormes
quand on travaille dans un bureau par
rapport à des avancées
quand même grâce avant tout au syndicat
quand même qui aussi au quotidien dans
les conventions collectives font avant
mais je dis pas que
tout à fait d'ailleurs pour remercier
pour son négociation mais voilà il faut
il faut vraiment le pays je pense c'est
quand même très fracturé avec beaucoup
de crise actuellement on n'a pas besoin
d'une crise en plus je pense que
maintenant je vous vois des choses très
dangereuses et qu'il faut plutôt apaiser
et lorsqu'il y a des choix compliqués à
faire les Français seront prêts à le
faire mais il faut bien leur expliquer
la situation avec des vrais chiffres
objectifs de la situation et derrière
toutes les opportunités qui sont
ouvertes est-ce que annoncé
une politique d'apaisement je pense que
la syndicats c'est que après un
mouvement donc auquel j'ai contribué
aussi et que je peux voir qui est
pacifique on voit qu'il ne se passe rien
pas un seul mot de la première ministre
sur les millions de Français qui sortent
sur des villes de province où il y a
d'habitude de pas grand chose avec des
responsable ces gens-là
qui est très fort et je pense que le
ballon doit l'entendre et le fait que le
gouverne ne bouge pas en fait si la
violence elle vient les manifestations
et on peut le voir malheureusement que
progressivement il y a de plus en plus
des chauffeurs qui arrivent mais
pourquoi ça arrive ça ça arrive parce
qu'on n'est pas entendu et donc quand on
a des millions dans la rue et qu'on se
rend compte que finalement le
gouvernement ne réagit même pas pas un
seul mot pour les manifestations de la
part du gouvernement à part à part en
profiter pour attaquer le l'Assemblée en
disant que tu serais beaucoup mieux dans
la rue
chose que même du stop connu qui avait
du monde dans la rue que c'était c'était
bien ensuite après de de d'initier le
débat avec notamment qui doit décider où
est-ce que c'est le Parlement c'est
quand même un vrai problème de de
démocratie alors là vous avez et on le
voit bien enfin
dans le question que je vous posais
aussi ce qui veut le problème c'est que
les experts eux-mêmes ne sont pas
d'accord entre eux sont les mouvements
se répartissent en trois groupes il y
avait un article dans son ange qui vous
montrer ça c'est c'est c'est alors ça
pose quand même un problème parce que si
même les experts ne sont pas d'accord
euh
si le message qu'on envoie mais juste de
mots sur les sur les sur les
manifestations je crois que c'est
François Giroud qui disait en France
c'est un peu paradoxal mais on fait
grève on négocie après et j'ai
l'impression que on en est encore là
peut-être que les syndicats attendent
d'un mouvement plus floue pour espérer
négocier faire reculer le problème c'est
qu'on risque d'avoir le pourrissement de
la situation et au final tout le monde
sera perdant dans cette situation
maintenant sur les sur les avis
d'experts on part du principe que
pourrait être violent et pour aller très
vite au sujet on pourra avoir
l'impression que certains mettent
l'idéologie avant la théorie c'est à
dire que il est assez normal enfin je
suis économiste et pour moi ça semble
naturel l'économie c'est pas comme ça
des réponses exactes c'est une science
molle donc forcément l'économie est
composée de courant et chaque courant a
des priorités des présupposés essayent
d'avoir une certaine cohérence politique
aussi et donc on va mettre en avant on
va penser on va poser des hypothèses qui
seront conformes aux attendus politiques
que l'on a aux éléments qu'on souhaite
mettre à corriger en priorité une
réforme est fait pour corriger donc si
on a une sensibilité plus sociable plus
à gauche on va aller sur des éléments
qui seront plus dans la redistribution
si on en a une sensibilité alors je
parle assez très
maniquer mais plus à droite et plus
libéral on va considérer que le marché
peut résoudre les choses on va dire
cette répartition ce système para
répartition vous défendez certains
disent ils sont pas nombreux mais il en
existe quand même disent une dose de
capitalisation finalement ce serait une
solution et voilà et le pire c'est que
en France il y a que l'État qui a fait
cette expérience de la capitalisation
donc sur les fonds des fonctionnaires et
donc c'est une possibilité mais à partir
du moment où chaque économie fasse
chaque courant de la pensée économiste
économique amène à des développements
des raisonnements scientifiques mais
avec des hypothèses un peu différentes
au départ on a l'impression que ça ne
communique pas et que on va prendre un
courant et avec ce courant on fait un
résultat reconnaissez que si tous les
été économistes nous disaient ah oui il
faut faire absolument cette réforme ça
serait quand même plus simple où il faut
pas quel but quel objectif
soit un peu perdu puisqu'on parle juste
revenir sur la question des syndicats
sur la pourquoi on fait grève avant
avant de négocier parce que souvent on a
aussi un patronat et une direction qui
refuse souvent de négocier le principe
et donc les syndicats sont obligés de
faire grève et de bloquer pour obtenir
quelque chose on prend toujours très
fort dans le dialogue social prends
l'exemple de l'Allemagne en Allemagne
l'Allemagne
statutairement ils ont un tiers du
pouvoir des entreprises dans les grands
groupes industriels ils ont représentent
ils sont dans le présentativité très
différente
mais c'est c'est
ça parce que en France le ca c'est que
les propriétaires du capital
d'entreprise c'est pas les producteurs
de la richesse les travailleurs donc si
on avait une meilleure répartition c'est
syndicale avec plus de pouvoir à
l'intérieur des entreprises forcément ça
marcherait mieux le capitalisme ce sont
les propriétaires des moyens de
production le salarié
pour recevoir une rémunération celui qui
prend le risque c'est celui qui amène le
capital donc il a peut-être le droit de
décider un peu plus que celui qui vient
le matin avec son contrat qui ne prend
qu'un risque et qui euh
c'est une logique qui est un peu un peu
différente
quand on participe c'est la
redistribution de
on doit répartir le risque sur sur les
travailleurs et le système coopératif
par exemple comme ça c'est ce que je
vais vous faire dire et le capitaine
c'est que du travail voilà
non le capital c'est du travail mort et
donc c'est bien le capitaine c'est que
l'accumulation du travail du travail
passé donc les travailleurs qui
produisent la richesse et qui
contribuent à ce capital
contre particulier
parce que il faut la démocratie le
travailleur à son mot à dire aussi dans
la direction de l'entreprise je prends
des risques avec les décisions Geoffrey
tout à l'heure du rôle de Parlement et
de débat un peu dévastateur qui a eu qui
eux parlons et ben ça n'empêche pas
qu'il y a une député qui est qui a eu le
prix du troubidoscope le prix de député
de l'année et c'est Aurore berger Aurore
berger honoré élu Yves vinoise et
présidente du groupe Renaissance a reçu
le titre de député de l'année 2022 lors
de la cérémonie des Prix du à
l’assemblée nationale ce jeudi 16
février le jury composé de journalistes
récompense les personnalités politiques
dont le parcours a été remarqué ces 12
derniers mois
un peu émue pour tout vous dire qu'on a
été élu pour porter des convictions pour
les assumer et je crois que c'est ça
qu'on attend de nous et puis on attend
aussi qu'on exerce ce mandat avec
beaucoup de dignité la dignité parfois
elle s'échappe un peu elle s'évapore un
peu de l'hémicycle et c'est à nous
d'essayer de lui remettre selon les
membres du jury pugnacité et consensus
caractérise Aurore berger première femme
présidente du premier groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale en parallèle de sa
maternité ont été des critères de
sélection au titre les lieux politiques
succèdent à la chef de l'hémicycle Gael
Brown Pivet elle aussi Illinoise je
crois que les électeurs peut-être s'ils
sont pas trompés on est misant des
femmes qui ont je crois du caractère qui
sont plus gnasses qui sont déterminés
comme l'agence qui m'a remis le prix la
dit résiliente en ce qui me concerne je
crois qu'en effet c'est peut-être un
qualificatif que je peux employer c'est
une manière de rendre hommage quand même
au dévouement des politiques c'est une
manière de sanctionner aussi les
résultats parce que c'est une
compétition là la politique et puis pour
moi c'est une manière aussi de montrer
qu'il y a quelque chose qui nous dépasse
tous politique et journaliste qui est la
République qui est la démocratie de
nombreuses personnalités ont été
distinguées pendant cette 31ème
cérémonie des Prix du Trombinoscope
Fabien Roussel secrétaire national du
Parti communiste français a été élu
révélation politique 2022 et Gabriel
Attal chargé des comptes publics ses
vieux remettre le titre de ministre de
l'année
sur les réseaux sociaux il y avait eu
des attaques absolument extrêmement
dégueulasses sur elle mais c'est vrai
que c'est il y a quelque chose qu'on
peut remarquer c'est la présence des
femmes quand même dans ce débat il y a
il y a une première ministre il y a une
présidente de l'Assemblée il y a une
présence de du du groupe majoritaire ce
qui est la première fois dans l'histoire
de la République c'est un c'est
important
le combat si vous n'êtes pas d'accord
dans les yeux
il traverse toute la société et des
femmes oui on peut que s'en féliciter
c'est une bataille de tous les jours et
moi je suis très fier de faire partie
d'un parti qui de qui historiquement
depuis toujours en fait toujours battu
du côté des femmes il y a déjà au début
être les premiers à faire à faire élire
des femmes qui étaient à l'époque qui
était à l'époque femme à la tête du
parti communiste
général j'ai dit une bêtise et même même
historiquement dans la dans
l'International
différent en tout cas voilà on a on a
été toujours dans ce combat là et donc
nous on peut être que très heureux que
c'est la bataille là maintenant traverse
les parties et que tous les parties s'en
emparent et qu'aujourd'hui on arrive à
un stade où une femme peut être aussi
incompétente qu'un homme à des postes de
responsabilité
pourquoi pas elle elle continue son
militantisme après on peut être d'accord
ou pas d'accord moi je trouve ça très
bien qu'on puisse elle aussi elle se
fait beaucoup attaquer je pense que
c'est important de respecter toutes les
voix que tout le monde puisse exprimer
elle exprime sa vision du féminisme on
peut être d'accord ou pas d'accord mais
en tout cas je trouve qu'elle fait
avancer les débats quand même et
qu'après elle elle n'est qu'une dans
l'assemblée d'après donc après tu
préserves qu'on est plusieurs la
dernière phrase c'est l'homme c'est
lâcher
cela dit
c'est vrai que le débat sur la
démographie n'est pas intéressant c'est
vrai qu'il aurait pu y avoir une grande
loi sur la démographie entre nous le la
question de la retraite d'ailleurs
vraiment
on a le temps de parler un peu de ce
phénomène je sais pas si vous en êtes
des clients de chaque GPT
alors on va parler de ce DPD
[Musique]
alors c'est un robot un agent
conversationnel et c'est quelqu'un qu'on
peut interroger tu as absolument tous
les toutes les questions et qui donnent
des réponses à tout à tel point que il a
été interdit je crois si on se peut je
sais pas si dans l'université
il va être interdit enfin
qu'est-ce que vous diriez d'ailleurs si
des étudiants
l'utiliser je pense que peut-être que
déjà il utilise
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
d'après ce que j'ai pu voir pour
l'instant finalement c'est un accès à
d'énormes bibliothèques on pose des
questions et visiblement quelqu'un l'a
testé un prof à tester et dit bon il
peut répondre aux questions mais quand
on veut creuser argumenter c'est bien là
où ce qui m'intéresse moi c'est que
l'étudiant sache argumenter qui trouve
l'information bon aujourd'hui la
formation la trouve plus rapidement
qu'hier certainement mais après que
fait-il de cette information argumenter
trouver un moyen de finalement apporter
sa pierre d'essayer de de mettre en
perspective donc ça pour l'instant
apparemment chat gipiti n'est pas
capable de le faire il y a quelques
limites alors il y a des erreurs aussi
alors certains nous disent oui mais on
apprend par l'erreur donc finalement
pour ceux qui font du code pour les
informaticiens c'est pas gênant on va
gagner du temps ils causeront à notre
place et des gros erreurs les erreurs
sont tellement grossières qu'on peut les
voir on les corrige donc pourquoi pas à
prendre par l'erreur là on pourrait dire
est-ce qu'on va interdire j'espère qu'on
va pas interdire parce que quand on
interdit on crée un peu ce qu'on fait
avec les enfants on leur dit tu ne
touche pas au pot de confiture l'envie
sera-t-elle que on va vouloir toucher
donc
ridicule de dire on va interdire
l'intelligence artificielle parce que il
va falloir savoir
pour l'instant il y a très peu de
conclure dans les concurrents qui s'y
essaient encore plus de mal donc c'est
pas encore avéré
après c'est une question de d'abord on
peut demander deux choses on peut on
peut réactiver et et réappuyer sur le
côté des les épreuves importantes se
font en présence dans un amphithéâtre ou
dans une salle et là il y a pas d'accès
vous vous posez la question des gens
comment est-ce qu'on s'en aperçoit moi
je vois que mes étudiants si c'est
travail quelque chose j'ai pété il y a
pas de fautes d'orthographe donc je sais
que c'est pas eux donc ça c'est la
première chose mais donc il y a moins de
fautes mais il y a aussi beaucoup moins
d'idées il y a pas il y a pas la
richesse qu'on a parce que comme le dit
tout à fait Patrick c'est une
compilation de
dedans
mais
pendant par exemple des concours de
l'agrégation de droit par exemple
vous avez une équipe et vous avez un
sujet et vous allez chercher dans les
bibliothèques ce que pourrait vous
donner cette GPD au fond c'est la base
la base de de la connaissance et puis
après il faut construire quelque chose
c'est non vous trouvez pas que c'est en
réalité je pense mais si vous avez
besoin par exemple si vous avez une aide
pour aller trouver tous les arrêts du de
la Cour de cassation sur un sujet précis
bon
c'est pas aussi c'est pas plus mal que
si on est obligé de le faire
ça ça existe déjà sous d'autres formes
après je rejoins parfaitement ce que
vous disiez tous les deux en réalité le
chat GPT c'est un outil formidable parce
que ça permet de générer du langage mais
ça a quand même s'en extraire limite qui
est que ça ne génère aucune authenticité
ni aucune originalité des choses très
donc un peu décevant sur le voilà ça te
prend aucun risque voilà ça me prend
aucun risque donc pour l'instant
effectivement c'est un outil qui existe
c'est un outil qui est quand même encore
extrêmement perfectible est-ce que un
jour Jean-Charles publiera un livre qui
avait fait uniquement à base
d'intelligence artificielle revêtement
on l'état
je ne pense pas parce qu'il y a un vrai
vrai déficit d'originalité et aussi pour
prêcher un petit peu pour ma paroisse
c'est ce qu'un jour un robot est rappelé
dans une cour d'assise ou un tribunal
correctionnel à mon avis eu égard à
cette difficulté concernant le manque
d'originalité je ne pense pas non plus
donc peut-être
il pourra juger il pourra juger
peut-être
je pense qu'à nouveau il y aura une
appréciation humaine qui ne peut pas se
faire avec l'intelligence artificielle
pourquoi c'est parce que parce que non
il faut il faut imaginer que
l'intelligence artificielle elle évolue
enfin c'est pas juste des connaissances
qu'on a et qu'on recrache on crée
quelque chose elle crée quelque chose
elle pourra sans doute mais à nouveau
son expérience
à une expérience
officiel de façon
d'appui jamais une source de décision en
tant que tel à mon avis
je partage le fait que aujourd'hui on va
vivre avec l'intelligence artificielle
c'est quelque chose qui est très
pertinent puisque ça peut nous faire
accélérer énormément sur beaucoup de
sujets et beaucoup de travail je pense
notamment à la cartographie je peux
travailler un petit peu avec l'hygiène
là-dessus ils vont énormément accélérer
et avoir des données beaucoup plus
précises sur le territoire par exemple
ce qui a plein de retombées
intéressantes et c'est plein de données
qui sont intéressantes changements
climatiques aussi pour pour avoir tout
ça la vraie question pour moi là-dessus
c'est que
tous ces Ia sont développés par
trade très petit groupe et encore une
fois mon axe moi c'est toujours la
démocratie et pour moi les gens on doit
construire des choses pour leur intérêt
à eux et donc il faut s'assurer que on
ait une gouvernance de saisir qui soit
vraiment démocratique et qui respecte
aussi nos droits nos droits individuels
et donc il faut réussir à construire des
gouvernances encore une fois mais on
pourrait cacher les Européens
s'intéresser peut-être plus il me faut
ça au chinois
oh là là c'est dangereux il faut que
l'Europe et c'est c'est un bon argument
pour pour que les Européens travaillent
ensemble il faut qu'ils travaillent
ensemble pour avoir leur logiciel on est
tous les moyens pour le faire et des
intelligences pour le faire et il
faudrait peut-être qu'on n'a pas les
médias pour le faire contrairement à ce
que font les gens des femmes on peut les
trouver
un livre qui n'a pas été écrit par
l'intelligence artificielle c'est le
produit qui n'a pas été récompensé par
un juridique
donc il vient d'avoir le prix du salon
de nœux-les-mines qui a un gros savon de
salon des mines noires dans le Nord qui
a un salon très important dans le dans
le monde du roman policier et qui se
passe bien enfin dans le Nord le salon
et c'est une histoire prodigieuse à
tiroir qui démarre dans les années à la
fin ouais ça ça démarre dans le Nevada
et ça va emmener le héros a rencontré un
certain nombre de vedettes d'Hollywood
avec vivre quelques catastrophes et
rencontrer Houdini enfin je veux dire ça
ça s'étale sur Oui sur euh quasiment 90
ans c'est extrêmement original avec un
ensemble de de twist comme on dit avec
un mot horrible mais de twist dans le
roman et Serge de Burg il est
l'auteur en fait il s'appelle Christophe
Dubourg et crise de Burg c'est un une
sorte de pseudo américain pour un
Américain americanisé le récit qui se
passe là-bas et parce que c'est un petit
peu un hommage à une littérature un
petit peu
borisant et voilà donc mais c'est tout à
fait tout à fait plaisant c'est le
deuxième prix qui a ce livre donc le
prodigieux détective aux éditions La
Joie dit merci à tous il est parce qu'on
a dépassé un peu mais il faut se quitter
quand même tant pis à très vite pour un
nouveau pape
[Musique]